Welcome back everyone there's been so many people
yelling at marvel to bring doctor doom into
the new marvel movies the new mcu turns out they
already did it in doctor strange too we all didn't
notice although if you were one of the people that
felt like there were some doctor doom easter eggs
turns out you were totally right the director
and the writer were talking about the doctor
doom scene it's also a cool easter egg for the
fantastic four just in general and for king the
conqueror confirming a lot of our theories marvel
also confirmed that they're gonna do a big marvel
phase four marvel phase five comic con panel this
summer in july so they're gonna reveal a whole
bunch of big stuff cheaply among those what's
going to be happening with the next secret wars
arc that they teased during doctor strange 2
and probably a lot more fantastic for an x-men
stuff too of course i'll do videos for all that
stuff so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're also
still doing the thor love and thunder imax ticket
giveaway too all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and post all your doctor doom fantastic
four theories in the comments below all my thor
love and thunder post credit scene videos easter
egg videos for the entire movie review videos
we'll start posting when the movie comes out i'll
post my review of the movie as soon as they let
us do that but according to sam raimi the director
and the writer of the movie the really cool doctor
doom scene happens when john krasinski's read
richards of the 838 universe fantastic four enters
the room for the first time and this is the clip
of them talking about that just doing commentary
for the movie so really cool reveal if you listen
to the commentary shot of lynch lynch was pleasure
to work with reed richards of the fantastic four
so is john hello steven teleportation
device he uses to get into the scene
is something we took from the comics that's
doctor doom's time door platform stephen but
it's not the scarlet witch that we fear and while
it is not professor x's first time on screen it is
the first time we see that uh hover chair from
the animated series reed richard is my favorite
marvel comics character so it was a real honor
to write his first entry i guess here in the mcu
so there's a lot to unpack in that john krasinski
fantastic four stuff that sam raimi and the writer
are talking about but the really important part is
all the stuff about doctor doom they're confirming
that reed richards portal technology is the same
technology that the tva is using allowing him
to travel across time and space not just across
space confirming that it's based on their version
of doctor doom's time travel platform which is a
huge comic book deep cut that also confirms that
he's using quantum energy to power it which
was a big theory of ours like he'd be using
quantum energy because the portal looked very
similar to tva portals it's just that it's blue
colored instead of orange colored if we know all
of kang or he who remains time travel platforms
the tva portals that they use and iron man's
time travel platform during avengers end game
is also powered by quantum energy and if you
didn't realize too iron man's time travel platform
is also based on the concept from doctor doom's
time travel platform it's just a very different
looking kind of platform the one in doctor strange
2 is more literally meant to be a copy of doctor
doom's time travel platform because of the way it
looks here the reason why his portal would be blue
in doctor's training to probably just because
the difference in the actual technology behind
the portals themselves the version that kang uses
in the distant future the tva technology would be
vastly vastly more advanced so this means in the
838 universe john krasinski's reed richards had
already encountered a version of doctor doom makes
sense this is kind of like the wish fulfillment
most comic bookie universe that we've ever been
to inside the mcu multiverse like every big easter
egg from the comics mixed together in a bucket put
on the illuminati together which themselves are a
huge easter egg for the team in the comics so this
version of reed richards would have had a version
of their comic book history together with doctor
doom in school doctor doom's origin story is also
connected to the history of the fantastic four
when they were attending school they kind of did
a version of that backstory during the classic
fantastic four movies at fox you know you made
a lot of folks at mit feel like a junior high
science fair so you'll excuse me if i save her at
the moment and this 838 universe version of reed
richards developed his portal technology based on
doctor doom's time travel platform meaning that
their doctor doom had already figured out time
travel and built a version of it like in the main
mcu 616 universe is iron man who's the one to be
the first to figure out time travel building his
time travel platform you have to imagine in this
universe it was doctor doom being the person to do
that and then this version of reed richards just
improves on that design basing his portal take
on it because the writer said that this version
of the 838 universe fantastic four backstory
and doctor doom took more from the comics you
have to imagine that this universe's doctor doom
also created his time travel platform for similar
comic book reasons like all the illuminati stuff
with them versus their version of thanos and their
version of avengers infinity war is all completely
separate from the doctor doom stuff it sounds like
in the comics the whole reason why doctor doom
created his time travel platform is because he
wanted to go back in time to try and find some
magical artifacts called the stones of merlin we
know that merlin is an actual real mcu character
that existed and that means that there's also
probably an 838 universe version of the character
too merlin for example is the one who forged the
black knight's ebony blade that we learned about
in the eternals movie he was a real character
who lived in camelot camelot was a real place
king arthur the round table all that stuff was
real in the history of the mcu the eternals talk
about living amongst them when that was going on
is that the ebony blade excalibur
arthur always did have a crush on you that's why
sprite asks angelina jolie's thena character if
she's using the ebony blade when she's swinging
the sword around she says no this is excalibur
like they literally have excalibur on the domo
their ship just sitting there the funny thing
about that because we're talking about real
stuff inside the mcu that actually existed
there's probably records about all that the
ebony blade excalibur camelot king arthur
merlin and kamar taj like merlin was
probably the sorcerer supreme of his era
the cool connection between doctor doom and
kang the conqueror here is that originally
in the comics kang the conqueror developed his
first time travel machine after stealing plans
for doctor doom's old time travel platform
and just enhancing them with his future tech
kang's original name is nathaniel richards
he's actually the son of reed richard's father
from a different family line so he's related to
reed richards but very very distantly but in the
future he's a historian he learns about doctor
doom's time travel platform so he just steals the
plans for it because it's ancient his first time
travel mission was to go back to ancient egypt
and set himself up as rama tut getting the people
to worship him as a god instead of the actual any
pantheon of gods like conscious pantheon there
were a couple scenes in easter eggs during moon
knight where they referenced this they talk about
this thing called the great rift the reason why
those gods basically turned away from man and now
they're just using avatars blaine kang for all the
bad things that are happening right now especially
secret wars there were also some easter eggs for
the rama kang and he who remains office during
the loki finale just confirming the connection
like oh in his backstory at some point he actually
did all this stuff the cool connection back to the
eternals and the celestials is that when kang
got bored with all this he left his empire to
apocalypse he became ruler apocalypse got all his
advanced technology that you see him with in the
comics from the celestials after making a bargain
with them celestials i've come here to bargain
basically helping them do the same thing that
the eternals do just increasing the population
to help hatch the new celestial faster we haven't
seen apocalypse in the mcu yet make all the oscar
isaac jokes that you want because he played
both apocalypse and moon knight now in the mcu
but because in the 838 universe we already know
x-men exists that means the version of apocalypse
probably exists and because they're a very comic
bookie x-men the animated series inspired version
of the x-men like he has that floaty chair the
version of apocalypse in this universe also
probably looks like the x-men the animated series
version of apocalypse maybe he also sounds like
oscar isaac my big theory before they confirmed
the doctor doom connection was that he who remains
kang has stolen his first time travel machine from
iron man's belongings like in the distant future
he takes iron man's designs for his time travel
platform from avengers end game and starts with
that before creating more advanced time travel
machines and all the tech that the tva wound up
using eventually with their portals but because
they formed the council of kangs that he talks
about like he literally talks about them sharing
technology across universes coming together in a
council that was all before the first kang
multiverse war it's possible that they also
shared plans for doctor doom's time travel machine
instead of iron man's meaning that he who remains
kang even if he didn't come from a universe
where there was a doctor doom might have gotten
those plans for doctor doom's time travel platform
instead of iron man's time travel platform what'll
probably happen though in the upcoming movies
is it we'll see a new version of doctor doom on
screen inside the new fantastic four movies or
whatever sequels they wind up doing hopefully
we'll also see a silver surfer and a galactus
easter egg pretty soon too and now because they
seem like they're building up to a big secret wars
arc like we have the infinity saga movies now it
seems like we have the secret war saga of movies
they're probably more and more stuff from the
multiverse so it sounds like now the main place
where we'll see x-men mutants even fantastic four
characters come is from the multiverse i think
mostly just because it's easier than explaining
how they were around on earth this whole time in
the main 616 universe and we just never learned
about them but some of these characters probably
will originate from the main 616 universe it's
just that it's much easier to use the multiverse
to explain where they've been this whole time
and the big reminder on the upcoming marvel
comic-con panel so this is actually a big
deal because they skipped comic-con the last
couple of years it's been a while since we have
like a really big marvel comic-con panel they're
basically doing the exact same thing at the end of
july and because this is comic-con we're talking
about is probably just for the really big movies
they have a special disney plus day happening in
september for all the tv stuff that marvel's doing
so the trailers that they're probably gonna give
us at this upcoming comic con is the black panther
2 trailer like the official trailer because that's
literally the next movie that's coming out after
thor love and thunder and we'll have already seen
that movie when the comic-con panel happens we'll
probably get a guardians of the galaxy teaser
trailer a captain marvel 2 trailer or teaser
of some kind for the marvels movie an ant-man 3
quantum mania trailer or some teaser of some kind
and they'll probably update the marvel phase
4 schedule with other movie announcements
like these are the movies that we're doing and
these are the dates that we're releasing them
like the blade movie deadpool 3 the fantastic four
movie the new x-men movie that they're working on
probably some surprise announcements like they
literally just announced that they're doing a
thunderbolts movie and they'll probably confirm
that we are now firmly in the secret wars arc of
movies like this is the thing that we're building
up towards secret wars battle world it'll be a
little bit different from the comics but it'll be
pretty cool i've already done a bunch of videos
about this i think that they're going to be using
kang to be the central figure and all this with
the kang multiverse war instead of god emperor
doom but a lot of it taking more inspiration
from the more recent version of secret wars not
the classic 80s version of secret wars so with
all the incursions i'm expecting them to lean
more heavily on the kang multiverse war than
on say like the beyonders but they've already
explained that there are a number of different
ways for incursions to happen like doctor strange
and spider-man led to other incursions happening
through their own actions but everyone post all
your theories in the comments below and if there
are any other doctor doom easter eggs that you
spotted in doctor strange too that i didn't talk
about in the video just write them below in the
comments congratulations curtis havingar you're
the giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click here
for my brand new thor love and thunder celestials
trailer video and click here for my full ms marvel
episode 3 video with showing she easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!